I like that the eyelashes matches my
chest hair today I'm trying on some fake
eyelashes never thought I'd see the day
you girls wear eyelash extensions is
that common I think they do it all the
time and I just don't notice I'm super
excited I feel like it's gonna be
glamorous you know I'll do what I can so
I have no clue what I'm doing
oh I think I just [ __ ] it up anything
where you have to put like glue on your
face just being immediate no like you
don't you know hell yeah I'm gonna kill
it might work this is not very easy to
apply a thin line of adhesive lll this
looks like semen so here we go oh I feel
like girls should be like bomb diffusers
because they're so good at like these
little tasks it's very high ooh I could
see the gap between many clashes in my
real lashes thank god this stuff dries
clear it's starting to feel like hard on
this eye it really does accentuate your
eyes like I have beautiful eyes I didn't
even know it's like a princess idea oh
god it feels like I have like a piece of
hair in my eye forever this is what
you're getting today I feel cool I feel
like Lady gaga I'm a good [ __ ] check me
out babe
wow that's a pain yes I'm sorry for any
woman or man who's ever done this it's
very feminine I wonder why my mind says
it's feminine looking I think it's cool
god I wish guys can accessorize and it
just not be an issue just don't like it
it feels weird I know have a newfound
appreciation for the skill takes to get
it right on where it should be feel like
with practice I could probably be like
the best god bless you if you do the
exam every day and letting Jesus Lord
God bless you